everyone its micro motor flows and this
is the or closed market recap for
Tuesday July 31st 2018 and it's kind of
interesting day some big movements late
in the day and in some of these markets
and before I begin let me just go over
the brief disclaimer again you know the
reason why I do these presentations you
know is to give people sort of an
insight into order flow analysis that
they probably wouldn't have you know not
out here saying this is the only way to
trade you have to do it like this no you
know people that know me people that
follow me and and and talk to me on a
regular basis about trading you know
understand what trading what is involved
in trading you know if you're just
coming to the markets thinking that oh
you know you know order flow is gonna
solve all my problems know it might not
you know it's it's something that you
have to put time and effort into learn
so this presentation is for educational
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation of buy or
sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision
futures train contain substantial risk
is not for every investor in investor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial investment risk capital is
my equity loss without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
training no those were sufficient risk
capital should consider trading past
performance not necessarily indicative
indicative of future results you know my
past performance not going to be your
past performance uh-huh let me rephrase
that you know you're not gonna trade the
same way as me you know everyone that
has a different way of thinking you know
and and sometimes I've come to realize
that one of the reasons why a lot of
traders lose money is they like to start
handicapping a trading method you know
rather than taking the trades when
they're their said well you know I don't
know I just I took it last time and it
didn't work out and I don't lose any
more money so I'm not gonna take the
trade the next time I'm always for to
start winning again before I start
taking a trades well if you're doing
that you're not going to be in the game
when the move start happening but anyway
I digress you know I could go on you
know I have conversations with with
people and it was really kind of
mind-boggling
what you know sort of the way they
approach trading you know I mean I'll
save that for another another video but
SMPS this morning this is an eighth
range chart and this is the order flow
straighter 2.0 version knowing the
latest version that we have and you know
there's a few new tools that we've added
in
there you know trap traders you can see
here traders are trapped right up here
you know we're looking for a market to
come back up to these highs breakout
make you know cash just opened up we
rallied up here then we're sort of
hanging around here you know people are
trying to think well hey are we gonna go
start rolling back up to you know above
eighteen and a half or not but also you
know these people are here are these
traders are trapped they're stuck you
know that they're long I've been wrong
you know they're trying to buy get
positioned in here for the market to go
higher they're not and the market starts
selling off but when when we come down
here got a prominent point of control so
you got some supportive buying you know
it tests that in the next bar and then
you know rallies up a little bit and
closes that bar pretty much unchanged
then it's a sells right back down to
that level goes through it then you come
down here to another area of support of
mine with mucousy didn't here with the
prominent potent controls now why is
this important is I mean you look at the
volumes you know you have five hundred
seventeen hundred nine hundred okay you
know even two hundred here you got
unfinished auction I'm not a big
believer an unfinished business but um
yeah it was just on my mind because I
was talking to somebody about it last
night and what happens well the market
next bar sells off cells off right down
here but then we start trading around
there we got another prominent point of
control we got some more support of
buying going on down here you can see
the blue right the blue blue that means
supportive buying you know this the pink
up here the magenta that's a resistance
selling and what does it market do you
know it rallies up to an area we got
resistance selling and that sort of that
area where earlier you know if you were
to look left you mean you can't trade to
the left of the chart but you know you
can look left four levels in the market
you know this was an area where earlier
you got some trapped Raiders and why is
that important is because you know when
the market starts coming back up there
you know are what's going to happen are
you gonna see that same buying that you
saw earlier or are you gonna see the
same selling that you saw earlier right
when you have traders that are trapped
you know what is it it's it's people
buying their trap because they're buying
it because they think the market is
going to go higher but their supply
there then you know they're buying is
met with supply and then market often
sells off you don't have trapped Raiders
around up here
you can tell in the order flow that
there's resistance selling if you're
using some of my tools now the other
thing to sort of keep in mind is you
know you got a swing high up here it
sort of corresponds to this earlier high
but um
watch the Delta what are you seeing up
here swing high you know if like I said
you know if you look to the left and he
sort of got at this area over here
where you know this is this he'd call
that a swing high because you know this
was really the swing high and we just
sort of hung around here but you know
you know that there's some resistance
selling up there so there's a potential
for the market to possibly sell off so
we're gonna look for you know look for
signs in the Delta - 200 - 475 - 500 and
what happens the market continues down
gets down here you know we weren't some
positive Delta market trades back and
forth rallies up a little bit you know
maybe this is half back here between
this this high and this the swing low
sort of starts coming back but then
watch this Delta you know it's just
positive the whole time start rallying
rally and rallying this is 9:30 in the
morning watch these point of control so
you know all the way up when it controls
are higher higher higher higher higher
higher that's a sign of a market you
know you're putting in higher opponent
controls in the bar you know that that's
an obviously that's a clear sign of a
market moving higher you know it's going
to be your support and you know when I
when I talk about you know if you're
sticking your neck out saying this is my
swing low okay so you're gonna start how
can you confirm it well you watch the
point of control is watch where the
market comes back to you have a point of
control right here market pulls right
back to it you know point of control
here market pulls back get steward buy a
couple ticks point of control right here
gets it holds buy it gets to it by one
tick an exponent control right to that
point of control exponent control two
ticks through here's three ticks through
this one's above it already so you know
you're not even pulling back to those
pointing controls you know the markets
got a full head of steam at this point
and obviously you put in some big
positive Delta numbers three thousand
seven thousand as you come up here to
this area up here where you get a
divergence right up here
look at this you have a divergence you
got your negative Delta you don't have a
ratio though you just got you know your
regular number up here six point four
nine it's just you know
order flow going through here does the
market sell-off yeah it sells off about
you know from say that what area is that
twenty-two and a half you know maybe
down to nineteen and down in here but uh
that's not much of a move honestly it's
just sort of going sideways sideways
sideways
you know this bar is interesting you got
multiple imbalances selling imbalances
one two three in here but you know watch
the Delta you know what are you looking
at right now you got the high of the day
here negative Delta a negative Delta a
negative Delta a negative Delta a
negative negative negative one positive
okay negative negative a positive
negative
you know at this point you know it's
predominantly negative Delta and is
what's the market doing just going
sideways but it's right off our high so
we got negative Delta so you know
there's a lot of there's their supply up
here right there's you know people
coming in here they're willing to sell
up here they're willing to sell then in
this bar here what do you get right here
you've got a primary point of control
you know you got some resistance coming
in here I mean you could even see it in
the order flow of 1000 1700 what happens
is you know over the next couple bars
that market sells off from 20 down to
down to 16 we're just so going sideways
before you break some more down to 15 so
you know this is a great sell right here
you know if you could have got short
around the 19 or 20 area you know you
could have taken it down for about five
points at least then when you start
rallying you know we got this swing low
here and this was interesting I really I
member looking at this and thinking you
know this one's interesting the way it's
breaking the way it's unfolding what do
you got well a couple of things you
coming down into a potential swing low
you don't know it at this point when you
hit the swing low if this is the low you
know if this is going to be the low but
this bar here with the ratio of two
point four seven six doesn't look like
it's going to be a low it's got a strong
negative Delta still next bar still
negative Delta next bar still negative
Delta this bar positive now what's going
on is you got sort of declining Delta -
mm - 1600 - 1000 and so what's that
telling you is well the aggressive
sellers are still there they're still
present but they're sort of lightening
up you know getting a little bit weaker
then he returns positive you traded
almost 20,000 you trade 19
thousand seven hundred contracts in this
one bar and you got Delta 78 which is
pretty much nothing I was pretty much
good might as well just be zero but it's
positive small positive and next bar
3,000 X bar 6,000 okay and you know this
is this is important because you got
negative Delta getting weaker here - mm
- 1600 - 1010 turns positive 78 389 3.96
592 here you got multiple imbalances as
well so you know you take those two
things put them together and you know it
can give you a nice trade I'll call your
going into the cash closed that's why
this one bar here it's got 41,000 next
bars got 51,000 but you know cash closed
you see a shitload of orders coming
through always every day it's like the
busiest time of the day
that's what everyone is they're trying
to get their futures off against you
know the people that run the index books
you know that's when they're most active
but anyway I'll get into another time
but what are you seeing any got buying
stack multiple mine and balances in this
bar so you've seen a shift in the Delta
- aggressive buyers you know is this a
worth taking a shot on this yeah heck
yeah I think it's worth taking a shot
you know we're gonna put your stop is
just below the swing low here you know
it's a little wide but this is a eight
range chart so you know what's your
potential your potential you're getting
along down here around you know the 18
level yeah you could be looking up here
at 23 or even earlier up there at you
know 25 and what happens the aggressive
buying you know we finally get through
all that volume we turn through it at
the cash closed and then the market
picks up its you know picks up that's
its head of steam again and it starts
rallying rally and rally and rallying
all the way all the way up to this high
up here at you know just before the just
before the futures closed in up here you
got prana port of control you got a
ratio you also got the divergence but
you know and that's not trade you're
really gonna take you know at 3:30 in
the afternoon getting short you only got
a short time period to even bother with
that trade but you know that without to
me I thought thought was
very interesting very very interesting
today interesting movie in the you minis
now buns I'll just go through that
really quick because you know buns is
you know people has asked me hey you
know I got a regular job but I want to
trade what market Shrek trade well you
know
get your ass up early and start trading
in the morning before you go to work
trade buns I open this is a nice
contract and now futures open at 1 a.m.
Chicago time buns the cash market opens
at 2:00 in Germany so can you trade them
precache well yeah you can volumes
decent but you know you're gonna get the
more true removes when go in the cash
markets open just as you know the
futures also trade for hours after the
cash closed in the buns but you get some
nice you get good moves in the buns it's
it's a nice contract to trade you know I
mean but you can start trading at 1:00
or 2:00 in the morning and don't wake
yourself up at 1:00 a.m. to start
trading
you could wake up at 2:00 get an extra
hours sleep but um
so you're rallying up here so you know
here right on the reopen the open rather
you know I'm not gonna take a signal
right on the open you know even within
30 seconds after the opening you know
give it some time to breathe here you
got divergence and nothing special here
you got another divergence nothing
special you know there's no ratios that
go with them either but you know so I'm
really not interested in those those two
trades right there but you know we start
selling off all negative delta is all
negative deltas you did have this bar
here about 130 for this morning probably
important control a little bit of a
sweep but not much it's kind of like
volume 44:47 34 then you come down in
here and you make a new goal you got a
divergence by the next bar you got a
ratio okay you know I like that but what
happens is it runs right up into some
resistance selling you know you got a
prominent pointing control up here and
then this is where got interesting sell
off to an area of support prominent part
of control here so I've got resistance
I got support you know basically be from
80 up to 87 and you can see how it just
sort of hangs around here trades back up
to you know 87 comes back down to 80 go
back up sort of comes back down finally
we break through a little bit you know
we get all the way up here to you know
90 91 where you got the primary point of
control then we just sell off nicely
down to the next support area down in
here yes this was a nice move as well I
mean I don't know if you'd be looking
forward to you know just keep bouncing
around you know we finally broke out to
the upside before you sold off you know
these are those those head fakes so it's
like people think well hey we're
breaking out finally up here you know
everyone wants to pile in and start
getting long those are those head fakes
before the market starts to sell off and
we came down here so you know be careful
don't be thinking that hey we're gonna
go buy it again here we're gonna go back
up yes that's not gonna go back and
forth all day long but you know
sometimes people like to think that and
that's where they go astray and end up
losing their money okay so come down
here you got divergence prime opponent
control this one fails you know it's met
with the red bar here then we just sort
of go sideways sideways sight oh he's
got divergence going sideways nothing
special then we get down here another
divergence nothing special that's why I
say don't just trade divergences because
on a market that's that's moving a
trending market you're gonna get that
multiple you don't get failed
divergences you know failed divergence
failed divergence failed divergence you
know it's like you'd be trying to pick
up a falling knife basically now this
one I thought was interesting you know
we had this swing low or the low of the
day rather over the ratio which I like
then you got a stack Bynum balanced you
know which is a few things that I like
in there yeah I love getting binding
balances at lows swing lows or lows of
days we rally yeah we rally not much
about six or seven ticks just kind of
hang around here go sideways this is
something here in the order flow but I'm
not gonna get into it is basically a
sign of you know you got your point of
control right in the middle of the bar
but it's it's a nice balance imbalance
in here that sort of portends a bit of a
sell-off I come down here another
divergence that fails and other
divergence that rallies up a little bit
and I think like I said you know if
you're looking for to trade divergences
by themselves don't you know look for
something else in in the market to you
know help confirm that you know hey
maybe this low can hold that's why I
thought this low can hold because I saw
aggressive buying coming in I saw you
know nice positive
you know and it's getting a bit stronger
as well unfortunately just sort of went
sideways until you got some bullish
signals they're in the order flow and
what happens in other divergents and
other divergence they both fail what
you're looking for is something else you
know like a ratio that's why you know I
talked about ratios it's not just about
looking at a number and say well there's
got a bullish ratio apposite you know or
a bearish ratio now you got to
understand what the ratios mean and how
to use them then you get down here to
these lows divergence with the ratio
divergence with the prominent point of
control so I got two divergences that I
like double bottom coming in here you
know to me this is this go time you know
what do you do you got to position
yourself long first bar yeah you had you
know it gave you the signal second part
also gave you the signal even got long
off the first bar you're not gonna be
getting stopped out because your stop is
gonna be you know just below the low of
the day here right you're getting in
somewhere around 45 46 and your stop is
below 40 you know 38 39 you know even if
you have it at 40 you know just which
would be a new low you're risking five
ticks right so imagine you're getting in
here at forty five what happens market
rallies rallies rallies rallies look at
the Delta again you know positive
positive positive you know you're
starting to get string together positive
deltas mark it's not going to move away
from the lows move higher from the lows
on negative Delta getting stronger you
know it's gonna move off the lows on
positive Delta getting stronger and you
can see how it rallies up there then it
starts coming back down get down in here
you know 8:30
you got this prominent point of control
here so you know you got some support
what happens rally up come right back
down miss it by a tick you just sell off
to one tick above that parameter point
of control before you rally back up or
do you rally back up to a resistance
area up here now you know people say
well you know you had that swing high
here you could throw an offer in there
yeah you can I mean there's nothing to
say that oh you wouldn't do that you
know when you're trading order flow of
course not you'd have it in there then
you'd see this primary point of control
and you think I might be you throw
another order in there to get short up
there knowing that hey you know I've got
some resistance selling up here that
this you know this retest of this the
swing high is got a good chance to to
work out
and we sell-off we software we sell-off
right down here we got prime opponent
control rallies up and it breaks down
again then you get down here to this
other low swing low what do you got you
got a prominent point of control again
you know watch the Delta you know say
you know I'll say I don't know if I want
to take this trade you know it's got a
small Delta 27 it could have been easily
been negative but you know if you start
analyzing the Delta you'll realize that
the way it sets up like that that's
actually quite bullish but then you know
watch the Delta so you're not convinced
here you know one from 27 to 206 1700 so
even if you get in late here said get in
on this bar after oh my gosh you know I
missed it you know got one 427 to 202 79
I better get long and you throw a bid in
here you're chasing the market you're
long at 52 it rallies all the way up to
62 or you got a prominent point of
control for a resistance selling then we
just sort of Bunning being you know test
it come off dust it and close for the
day so I mean that was the buns you know
it was quite interesting there in the
buns let me see if I got time to go over
the crude oil real quick all right so
I'll talk about crude oil real quick cuz
the only the interesting trade in the
crude oil
what's the based on primary important
controls but is based on something
slightly different but in a new feature
in the order flows trader software now
look at this this is 8:00 in the morning
Chicago time so we got it we got the low
of the day we've got a divergence here
we rally up rally up or we rally to this
area up in here where you have multiple
imbalances another bar multiple
imbalances you've got stacked imbalance
put in there you know this is why we
have multiple imbalances highlighted is
because so you can see that you know
what's happening in the market and you
know make that decision you know should
I get you know is this missus potential
swing high or swing low in this case is
this potential soon high well you know
you got some selling imbalances up there
and what happens in market sells off
sells off to this area down in here or
it's just you know found a point of
control tests it rallies back up but
then you've got a bearish boundary point
of control you sell off down you know
here to this swing low you have this one
here where you know there's market is
moving very who's fast market conditions
that's why so
fifteen you know there's all these zeros
in there but then you get down here and
look at this this little you have
trapped Raiders down here you've got a
bullish racial racial balance low and
the market rallies up where's it rally
up to it rallies up to this bar where
you got prominent point of control
market you know rallies you know it
doesn't say comes off this bar closes
lower next bar rallies back up and where
is it
hold it comes right up here to this
prominent point of control both times so
again you know if you're looking for you
know a second chance entry yeah you know
you can get it probably on these
prominent opponent controls market sells
off and this one this is this is why I
love this this feature the multiple
imbalances because you're not gonna
notice this you know our eyes are
trained to look for a stacked imbalance
they're not trained to look for multiple
imbalances and look at how those deltas
appearing 2197 176 you know I did just
sucks that it runs into this resistance
selling which sorta corresponds up in
here but then it comes right back so you
know even if you got long and you know
you know I got this prominent point
of control you got out of the position
the fact that we finally broke through
it if you're watching the Delta is you
know a couple that Delta with this
multiple imbalances here you know you
could be comfortable getting back into
the trade then a rallies up into the
swing high before selling off and again
you know watched appointed controls are
all being lower lower lower Delta all
negative you know went from you know was
getting a little bit weaker 361 then
went in the 139 at this turn it's minus
174 - 167 - 202 you know he's gonna
stick a fork in it that is done so that
was what you know I really I felt was
the most interesting thing is about
using the multiple imbalances in in
crude today you know it's sort of you
know help you pick up a few things you
know here sell off from this primary
port of control so not a big move on 10
ticks again another 10 ticks here you
know next bar starts poking lower before
it comes back up then again you always
it do it trades back back up here it
comes off again you know late in the day
there's some you know big moving the
crew down a few
yeah anybody noticed it yeah I got this
is what it looks like on a on a 15
second charge I think it looks more 15
second chart you know we broke 68 75 all
the way down 67
what is that 95 it's about a buck move
almost about 80 cents so anyway uh you
know that's what I just basically wanted
to cover today about what happened in
the markets now again it's what you what
you got to realize about order flow is
you know order flow is a tool okay and
you have to use it as a tool right it's
not a red light green light system you
gotta think you know yeah I see people
coming out there well you know trying to
come up with these methods with that
don't require any you know any thought
process well you know what is that what
is that is that is that training or not
you know the best decisions are the ones
that you make in life and you know yeah
you know I just looked courage because I
was going back and forth with somebody
on an email and guy was complaining that
I basically wanted everything for free
but then they say well then he'll pay me
and you know it's like you know I got
programmers to pay and then stuff like
that so you know if you're serious about
order if you're serious about trading
you know look into order flow if if
you're just gonna think that you know
trading is gonna be like some method
that is gonna turn around your life in
the next 24 hours it's not but if you
want to put in some effort to to
understand how the markets move and you
know history repeats itself then you
know order flow I think is it's gonna be
a great tool for you to use in your
trading so thanks everyone and have a
great day bye-bye